Morning. [music]
I'm Helena Chow, head of venture capital
and crossover coverage at Bank of
America, and I'm delighted to be here
this morning with my friend Amanda
McMaster, interim CEO and CFO of Boston
Dynamics.
>> Thanks, Helena.
>> To be here with you today.
>> So excited to be here.
So, seven months ago at CES, Boston
Dynamics was the darling of the show. I
mean, it literally felt like we're
waiting in line for a Disney ride to get
into your booth. The production Atlas
revealed on Handai stage, plus the
partnership with Deep Mind was a very
powerful combo. It was also the moment
that Boston Dynamics went from the
company that makes incredible robot
videos to actually shipping a real
product.
So, how do you think about what Boston
Dynamics needs to become in the next
chapter versus the company that built
the reputation?
>> Yeah, thanks Melina. Um, you know, we
came out with, you know, amazing
prototypes for years. Um, we've been
working on humanoids for the last 20
years. Um and when we made the decision
to productize this technology, it was
really important that we incorporate,
you know, everything that we learned
over the last say 6 years
commercializing spot and then stretch.
So what some people might not know is
that this is the third product we've
productized, third robot in one decade.
So we have spot which is our our
quadriped stretch which works in um
warehouses and does box moving and then
now we're moving into you know our
humanoid product. Um and the way that
we've really been thinking about this is
there's four pillars we believe that you
know anyone who wants to be in the
humanoid market needs to be thinking
about and they're I'll give them for
you. So it's does it perform? Is it
reliable and is it safe? That's
critical. Does it do something that's
actually important? Is it useful for
customers? Is there a customer ROI? Do
they have a plan for AI and the way that
you're going to capture the data needed
for these robotics foundation models and
scale? And then do you have a plan for
scalability? You know, we're so lucky in
in having Hyundai as as part of our
family, which we get to benefit from
both the vertically integrated supply
chain, customer relationships, um, and
and the entire ecosystem that they're
building, um, which is very unique in
the industry.
>> So, you came into this role from the CFO
chair. So you've had a front row seat to
the cost side, right, of this in a way
that most CEOs haven't. Um, which I
think is really interesting. And so when
you look at the trajectory of building
Atlas at scale, what is actually bending
the curve? Is it the design, the the
supply chain, is it the volume or is it
something else? And also how does
Hyundai factor in as your owner as your
first customer and your supplier base
allin one?
>> So the answer is yes [laughter] it it
from the cost side it all matters right
and and I think going back to this idea
of having done this before we understand
you know how important it was to create
a robot that was scalable right from the
start. So if you look at the design of
Atlas, you'll see that each of the arms
and the legs are interchangeable. These
are considered field replaceable. So our
customers and and even me, they let me
try to uh to to fix these and I can do
it in under five minutes and I'm not an
engineer. Um so you know, we've we've
thought about this because what are the
inhibitors to scale? What are the
challenges to making money? And it's can
you simplify simplify simplify? and can
you make this easy to service, easy to
manufacture? Um, and we've had, you
know, that in mind from the beginning of
Atlas. Um, even the head as new chips
are released, this is field replaceable.
Um, and we can be updating and not
redoing an entire robot design. Um, and
then of course, as I said, you know,
Hyundai, it it's great for us that, you
know, part of where you get that cost
inflection is enough scale and being
able to purchase at scale and then
produce at scale. um they're s they have
signed up as our first customer. They're
going to take between 25 and 30,000
worth of demand right off the top which
and build us a facility um they're
calling it robotics in America. So we
will have a manufacturing facility in
the United States um that is producing
all of our robots and really allowing us
to hit cost targets. So just to give you
an idea um between the the prototype and
D1 that was revealed at CES um we
simplified the design from eight
actuator types in the prototype to two
in D1 and we've seen cost savings
between 60 and 80% on some of the key
components utilizing the Hyundai
relationship.
>> That's amazing. That's super super
powerful and I think it it's really what
makes you guys stand out amongst your
peers. Thanks.
>> Um, Carolina Prada from Google DeepMind
is is also on stage later today. So,
your partnership pairs Boston Dynamics
physical AI with Google Deep Mind's
foundation models, but I know that you
said it's not as simple as the body
meeting the brain. How do you see that
division of labor evolving? And and
also, where does the long-term advantage
sit in your opinion?
>> Yeah. Um, I' I've asked this question a
lot. They're like, "Isn't you know,
isn't the, you know, Google Deep Mind,
the brain, the the robots, just the
chassis? It's it's not valuable." So, we
put this together to try to demonstrate
some of the differences here. Um, we
think about it as, you know, again, not
an engineer. I keep it simple, which is
there's really two brains. There is the
the physical skills that are necessary.
So, think about this in terms of what
Boston Dynamics is known for and we've
been doing for years. This is the
physicality of the robot, the ability to
um manipulate the environment, its
ability to have reliability. Um that is
purely ours. Um and when we think about
um uh the physical, so the uh physical I
mean sorry the u the semantic
intelligence so understanding the world
the reasoning models that's what we're
jointly developing with Google deep
mind. And then there's a third piece
that folks haven't really been talking
about yet that's embedded in that which
is how does it interact with the the
customers, the facilities, how do you
build tools and workflows or we've been
calling that the job harness piece of
this and that's very um customer
specific information that would
integrate into their environments. So
you need all of that for this to be
useful. And again, if one of our pillars
is customer ROI, building something
that's not just a cool prototype, but
that is actually useful in their
environments, we really believe you need
all of these layers.
So, um, 1X and Agility are also speaking
today and you're obviously, you know,
constantly compared to Figure and Tesla
Optimus.
>> Um, but Boston Dynamics has made a very,
uh, deliberately different bet. So the
design um the fully rotational joints
you know being enterprisegrade rather
than volume first. Can you share the
thinking behind this approach?
>> Yeah, I mean I think even though um it
we we seem like we're a little slower. I
would say it's really coming from years
of knowing that if you put a robot in
the world that isn't valuable and
doesn't solve a problem, it's it's not
going it's not going to be valuable for
our customers. they're not going to buy
it and we need them to buy it at scale.
So that's the first piece. And then in
terms of our joints and and and the
decisions we made for this is we don't
really want to be encumbered by the idea
of what our human body is capable of
doing. The idea is to be superhuman,
right? The reason to have robots is that
it can do things in a way that humans
cannot um and augment human labor. So we
don't need a replacement for humans. We
need something that's different. Um, so
we've been really focused on pushing the
boundaries of performance and seeing
what what we can make and we think, you
know, the efficiencies you get and being
able to turn the joints 360 degrees is
pretty amazing.
So, um, the question underneath all of
this, so for the operators and the
investors in the audience here is when a
humanoid actually pays for itself,
where do you see Atlas crossing that
line first? And what should leaders be
doing now to plan their workforce and
factories around it?
>> Yeah. So again, key learnings from
putting mobile autonomous robots in the
world is we really aim to have a 2-year
ROI on spot. We found that that's kind
of the the sweet spot for our customers.
They can really justify that. Um it
makes a lot of sense. It's the way they
think about industrial tools. And so
we're aiming for two years or less um
ROI for our customers.
And and that will be when when Atlas is
is able to cross over.
>> Got it. Um and I guess like a year from
now, so when this room is back together
next year, what's the one concrete
milestone that would tell everyone here
that physical AI has genuinely turned
the corner from promise to proof?
>> I think it's who has robots in the
world. Have you done real deployments?
If you don't have robots in there, then
we haven't really me met the inflection
point, but I we're prepared for it. So,
we're ready to put them in. We have our
spots in the world. We're going to start
working with um we're calling it a
skills development lab next year. Um
outside of just Hyundai, we will have um
Atlas in customer hands. So, I think
that's going to be the mark for
everyone.
>> Can you maybe talk a little bit about um
where Spot is currently deployed? I
mean, you you'll all get to meet Spot in
a few minutes, but where where is Spot
currently being used?
>> Sorry, I'm going into other people's
presentations. Give me one second. Um,
so you're going to meet Spot in a
minute, but um we have Spot in um
industrial settings right now,
manufacturing facilities predominantly,
um anything in food and bev any anywhere
you have high value assets that you want
to do inspections on. So we do both
visual inspections um acoustic and
vibration detection and then you know
heat we call it thermal detection. Um so
we've we've seen a lot of um benefits
with within say Nasley Purina is one of
our um our key accounts you know they
have food manufacturing facilities and
so this is very helpful for them. We're
in Intel um where you're seeing us do a
lot of um inspection of their old
facilities. So, while they've made a lot
of renovations maybe on what we'll call
the second floor, the basements are
still largely, you know, dark and um
they have not been renovated and it's a
great use case for robots. You really
don't want to be putting humans in those
facilities. Um and so we're able to
provide value. Um we have a we have some
something north right of now of 600
customers over 46 countries. So there's
there's actually not another mobile
autonomous robot on the planet being
used as much as Boston Dynamics there.
We have somewhere around two million
inspections per quarter.
>> Wow. That's really powerful. Can you
maybe talk also about the you know
potential applications for Atlas? I mean
I would imagine it's similar type
facilities but with a different
>> Yeah, we're applications.
>> We're starting with Hyundai as you would
imagine. um you know as they've
committed. So we're going to start in
auto manufacturing. The way we're
thinking about the application journey
here is start where it one we know that
the tasks are repeatable. Um there's
been a lot of work done in those
facilities around safety and what it
means for humans to work along with
machines. So we feel like this is
repeatable, scalable activities. So
we're going to start in um in
automanufacturing
um with Hyundai. Um, we're going to be
working on job sequencings, part
sequencing, um, and then moving into
machine tending. And then, of course,
we're going to have other customer
applications outside of Hyundai, which
really aligns to the where Spot is
today. So, we imagine manufacturing
facilities will have very similar needs.
Um, that's the conversations we're
having today, and yeah, we're looking
forward to it.
>> So, on that note,
>> shall we have the audience meet Spot?
>> Yeah. Does everyone want to meet Spot?
I'm like, where is Abby? We have our
wonderful robot wrangler, Abby. We'll be
bringing out a spot up to the stage.
Everyone, this is Spot.
Hey Spot, what's going on? Good morning.
You excited?
Fist bump.
Um so spot is our mobile quadriped.
We have five sensors um stereo cameras.
Two in the front, one on each side and
one here that we finally call the robot.
[snorts] Um and there's also one in the
uh the gripper.
The way that you know as we said we're
we're using this particular morphology
um to do visual inspection. Um the the
arm allows for manipulation like opening
doors, turning valves, picking up almost
anything that you'll see on the floor.
And um if you've seen some of the recent
um videos we've put together with Google
Gemini, um we're doing um AIVI, so AI
visual inspection that allows for even
more manipulation tasks and
understanding of the world.
Very cool. Um,
>> and there's there's different
attachments, right?
>> Yes. So, we have different payloads.
Right now, we have an arm on there. If
we were putting this together for a
manufacturing facility, for example,
we'd likely have an acoustic sensor. um
we might have a thermal sensor on the
back and that allows for it to read
gauges or read um you know if there is a
gas leak air leak in any of these assets
um and report back. So the idea is goes
out into the facility it collects all of
this data very repeatably every single
time it can unlike a human it can go and
have the same exact position from
anywhere it is and then we feed this
into what we call orbit AI. So, this is
our platform where we're running all of
our data through. Um, it both serves as
a place for our customers to see like a
single pane of glass for them to see
where their robots are, but also allows
for them to engage with the robot. So,
for example, if I were to say, "Spotco,
take a take a visual inspection of this
facility. Tell me anywhere there were
puddles." You know, today it's pretty
hot. There's probably no puddles, but I
said, "Tell me if there's any puddles.
and also tell me anytime you find a
puddle and we're going to put this into
the into the system and figure out how
we can avoid this. You know, is there a
leak somewhere? Same thing with, you
know, when we start thinking about
health and safety, um, fire protection,
it can go and do those inspections and
then you have a Google street view. Like
imagine that you you click in, you can
get a 360 rotation of what your facility
looks like at any time. Were there
people in your facility that you didn't
want in there at a certain point? You
know, um did someone leave a ladder in
front of a door? There's a lot of
information you can gather um while
Spot's doing these inspections and
you're doing it and experiencing it all
through the Orbit AI platform.
Yeah. Thank you, Abby. Hi, Spot.
>> Very cute.
And you'll notice um Spot's a champ at
stairs, but likes to go down backwards.
It's a little bit safer. It utilizes uh
those cameras that are in its butt.
Is there anything else you want to say?
>> No, I think so.
Well, I think we're just about out of
time, but um please join me in thanking
Amanda for her time.
>> Thanks everyone. So happy to be here.
Thanks, Elena. [applause]